Operationen die mit Hilfe von Robotern
schneller präziser und damit viel
schonender werden sollen so entwickelt
nuralink für die Implantierung ihres
neuen brain machine Interfaces eigens
einen vollautomatischen Roboter für das
bisher gängige BMI von Blackrock nuro
muss ein Chirurg von Hand ein Loch in
den Schädel bohren das Interface wird
dann mit Druckluft ins Gehirn gepresst
kein Scherz die Elektroden von nuralinks
neuen BMI sind dünne Fäden die der
Roboter einzeln ins Gehirn einpflanzt
und dabei Blutgefäße aktiv vermeiden
kann dieser Prozess ist präziser
schonender als die alte Technologie den
Schädel kann der Roboter noch nicht
eigenständig aufbohren aber das soll
noch kommen wenn du jetzt mehr wissen
willst dann folge unserem Kanal und
schau dir das Video zu noralink an da
erfährst du unter anderem über